oh lord man just fraud me and pajamas it
ain't going down like that
[Music]
when i'm playing 2k i like to look like
myself because i don't want to be
anybody else
finishing close shot they're maxing that
out i don't miss close shots standing
dung
ain't no 50
interior defense
from guarding someone my height
clamps all right i think i'm squared
away get him squared away
[Music]
the city is amazing it really feels like
real life you get to walk around the
city get to go to stores purchase
clothes i have my own apartment like
this this is dope the fit can never go
wrong with a sleeveless hoodie and shoes
design ones
self-explanatory
my draft night went a little different
right it's bringing back a lot of
memories how nervous my character is i
remember being that nervous in real life
i think it's dope that you're able to go
straight to the league in 2k i think
just having that choice to have a high
school and they call out you in the
starting lineup instead of having a
college i think that's pretty dope
well i just got selected number 55 in
the nba draft
so everybody go get this working
put a bicycle my dude is swag
hey
we're going fast he's skating
rollerblading to the courts you know
he's about to serve somebody 50.
whether it's going to the gym whether
it's going to the gatorade facility i
think 2k does a great job with showing
his
it ain't no cakewalk you got a lot of
work to do if you want to become great
okay
nice little warm-up i do a lot of stuff
like this during the season it keeps
your agitate on point a lot of people
try to take charges on me so i always
have to be ready to make my second move
on the fly but
everybody gets stronger
the playground means a lot to me because
that's what me and my stepfather spent a
lot of time working out when i was
younger everybody played three on three
and i just want to say my teammate that
has the put back on is built different
you better be making shots
okay
one
two points in a rebound
bro what are you doing this man's
wearing a backpack playing
basketball wide open
oh god i have to carry though
okay
uh i'm finishing that in real life
oh
yeah we need points
thirteen six
i have all eight
thirteen eight
i'm sorry
that's not real
it's not real
so what is my teammate doing
what are you got going on
let me try name us like that
lost to a man who had pajamas don't act
like that let's go to the real court
let's see if you're gonna do that on the
real court